what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we have quite a bit of news we
have spider-man no way home news
concerning toby mcguire and andrew
garfield some venom let there be carnage
news the release date has now changed
big news about shanghai and how this
news has affected spider-man no way home
and venom let there be carnage we
actually have chiang chi to thank it's
just doing insanely well at the box
office right now even during kind of a
pandemic right now i know we're kind of
on the latter half of it but still even
with a lot of theater still closed shang
chi is crushing it and we'll talk about
why this is really good for other films
in this video and if you're new be sure
to subscribe so you can stay up to date
on all things in the mcu all things
happening with venom luther carnage and
of course spider-man no way home so like
i was just mentioning chang-chi is
absolutely crushing it it's projected to
do 90 million in its opening labor day
weekend and those numbers are impressive
as it is but considering the fact that
again not a lot of theaters are open
it's very impressive and this is really
good news and i'll tell you why if
shanghi didn't do that well in the box
office there was a chance that
spider-man no way home could have been
delayed now there still is a chance that
it could be delayed if venom 2 happens
to bomb but as of right now it's looking
like they're not going to delay it in
fact it looks like due to the massive
success of shang qi it looks like sony
and marvel are actually moving up venom
let there be carnage's release date
venom let there be carnage was
originally scheduled to come out on
october 15th however just today the
studio has decided to move it up to
october 1st that means we are now less
than a month away from seeing venom let
there be carnage now again this is most
likely due to the massive success that
shang chi had and when venom comes out
on october 1st if it does well that
means spider-man most likely won't get
delayed and i think even if it does
relatively okay they still won't delay
it i think it's gonna have to literally
bomb in the box office for them to delay
spider-man no way home i personally am
extremely excited for venom let there be
carnage but i think the studios know
that there was a lot surrounding chongqi
and there is just a ton surrounding
spider-man no way home so even if venom
let there be carnage doesn't do that
well i think they kind of realized that
the majority of people i would say are
more excited about shanghai and
definitely more excited about spider-man
no way home and i'm not trying to
downplay venom let there be carnage in
any way i'm super excited for this film
i actually really love the first one i
just think that spider-man is probably
the most popular superhero in the world
if not definitely like top three and the
good news is because chongqi crushed it
it looks like spider-man's still going
to be on schedule and speaking of
spider-man we have some news now in some
videos i have talked about some leaked
photos of toby mcguire and andrew
garfield both of them seemingly on the
set of spiderman no way home i did a
video last week talking about some of
these photos some certain photos of toby
and andrew talking about how youtube
channels that have posted these photos
have had their videos taken down some
twitter accounts and some instagram
accounts that had these photos up had
those photos taken down and some of the
accounts were even shut down briefly as
well this is typically a sign that the
photos are indeed real well it looks
like that has happened again and yes it
has happened again with a toby mcguire
photo and this time it actually got
taken down from reddit and this is kind
of big because reddit is the place where
really leaks are that and you know my
youtube channel but if there are any
types of leaks out there they end up on
reddit it's kind of the hub for
everything and the fact that the studio
actually took it down from reddit means
that they really don't want people to
see it and from what i've seen on reddit
they took it down due to a copyright
claim so as far as we're concerned right
now if there are some photos out there
that you've seen that look kind of real
that involve toby maguire and andrew
garfield there's actually a pretty good
chance that those were real now this is
hollywood's worst kept secret i mean
we've known about the other two
spider-man showing up in spider-man no
way home for over a year now so it's not
like this is kind of telling us anything
that we don't already know but trust me
i get it until we see them on screen it
is not confirmed but i think that could
be coming up soon based off all of the
rumblings and rumors going around online
it does sound like sony's plan is to
show the three spider-man together in
one of the trailers now this would
obviously make sense they showed us a
little bit of the sinister six before
with the full doc awk reveal alfred
molina's got but that still didn't
really tell us about the story we know
the multiverse is involved and we know
some of the previous villains are
involved but the trailer didn't
specifically say how these villains are
back it doesn't actually say if they're
from another universe or if they're
variants of some kind it just kind of
teased them so the next trailer should
give us a full backstory of all of the
villains that peter is going to have to
go up against and the help that he
should have aka the other two spider-man
so right now we're all just waiting for
that second trailer and hopefully the
rumors are true and it does indeed show
the other two spider-man as always if i
hear anything about spider-man no way
home i'll be sure to do an update video
on it so be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos and be
sure to comment down below what you are
most excited for about spider-man no way
home give the video a like if you
enjoyed it and of course for live
updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
you